is this it six zero six zero sorry Mega
should just off for a drop
you want half a point but lose the match
Mr silent of course someone would say no
but do you think that's per
sportsmanship to offer a draw yeah I
don't think you do it although I'm not
sure if it's for a sportsmanship would
be a bit of trolling
800 game
in this line he's very serious he keeps
playing the same line having an opening
debate
it's not because we know
before
yeah I don't think he's played a single
like Champions Chester match with so
many serious openings yeah
okay unironically I don't I'm not sure
if he has
no no
something yeah
well here is just sticking to E4
solid quiz gambas with black
all business
although you could also argue the
opposite of course that he doesn't have
any special preparation therefore he
just keeps playing the same line
because he doesn't have anything at the
sleeve but I prefer the reading that he
just takes this more seriously because
it's yeah it's more important to him and
he's never won
and I was hoping to give Peter heiner
Nielsen a day of work today so
I don't know I heard that prolonged golf
season in Lithuania like I'm not sure
Peter Hein is available
I think they've had more snow than we
have
I saw some pictures seemed a bit slow
if you want to know about Golf and the
weather in Lithuania check out the
chicken Chester vodkas it will be
covered in great detail in the first
half hour
then I'll talk to Laurel for half an
hour and then what's wrong with feeding
will be covered in great detail in the
final 30 minutes
the perfect format yeah I think we
cracked the code
Magnus likes the spawn structure
taking a lot of squares
and he can Shuffle
every day I'm shuffling
it does shuffle a lot
he's a shuffler baby
some can go E4 here this looks fun
takes takes
very random stuff
hitting the queen
the queen goes somewhere
and I can take can take here
if I didn't do it
you went 95 and now back to shuffling
94.
threatens to jump
B6 A5 trying to soften them but if I
hang out blender
is this what happened
no F5 to the anger piece no sure move is
this no no no but today it was his
position F5 was winning a piece
if 93
I'm not a piece
was winning
and the point is Knight takes D5 Bishop
takes a pin
oh that was a chance for for a point for
Selen
I took 25 allowing Knight C5 and now it
goes the other way now this Knight
is nasty yeah that was his chance
maybe I'll get another one
probably not also
maybe he's happy it's over like I'm sure
it's a fun experience to play the world
champion but Selena is a very strong
player like he's close to 2700 and just
lose every game doesn't matter if it's
uh in order to play the champion of fun
or whatever it's
it's
painful
yeah it's pretty much fun for him but
although I guess like from a training
point of view like getting to play these
quite serious positions against someone
like Magnus is pretty useful for even
someone as strong as
yeah yeah for sure and he probably won't
mind it but I'm sure this
it's rough but of course the experience
and to see how quickly Magnus spots
staff and poses problems and so on it's
must be nice although Salem I think he's
he's playing against a lot of strong
players and he's played Magnus in the
past and also I hear a lot about
training sales with very strong players
so there's no shortage of good
competition out there
uh what are you saying I guess is more
true long term that you might benefit
from it from yeah the learning and
thinking about it but in the moment
6-0
I didn't win that game
maybe seven zero
could be looks bad for black spinners
hard to shake
E4 he wants de95 I didn't know that
doesn't really
solve all the problems
Magnus thinking about it could also take
with the queen
this might be the final game of the day
yep went by so fast
tomorrow we have five more matches
what's yours excuse by the way why
didn't he play today
so you already had a flight apparently
that he forgot about
okay that sounds great 5 P.M
so I wanted to switch to 7pm but
unfortunately Corey wasn't available at
7pm we had a flight at five so you want
to switch to seven what kind of flight
is that I guess it was a short flight
do you play Bundesliga
I don't think so
so I don't know where he is or where
he's going or
it's all a mystery
it's all very very confusing
but he will play tomorrow
let me check if you play bonus leader
no
Magnus winning
he has two pieces of The Rook more pawns
will fall
it's very hard for black to ever attack
anything here all the white pieces are
so nicely defended
so this will be this will be the end
it's up on the clock thousand looks
upset but he did win 7-0
not sure why you're so upset